you're allowed to believe whatever you
want to believe whether some people
think it's absurd or not you're not
allowed to force other people to believe
and accept that yeah right this goes for
absolutely everything it goes Way Beyond
this issue this is our understanding of
religious beliefs political beliefs
social beliefs cultural belief right
everyone is allowed to believe what they
want there's billions of people in the
world we don't we don't all share the
same belief systems but if I were to
come and now try to force all the things
that I believe on someone else I can
believe that this this table is circular
and yellow I have a right to believe
that I don't have a right to try to
force everyone else in this room and
everyone else in the world to to believe
and accept and say that this table is
circular and yellow when they can see
it's rectangular and black